Wolverine.
Logan.
James Howlett.
Whatever you call him, the facts remain the
same: Wolverine is the best there is at what
he does — and what he does usually isn't
very nice.
But just how big a jerk is he in the comics?
Here's a look at the most terrible things
Wolverine has ever done.
He drowned his own son
Wolverine has a whole lot of descendents,
which is just par for the course for a near-immortal
animal-guy with poor impulse control.
The worst of them all, though, is his son
Daken, who inherited his father's mutant abilities
and bloodlust, only without that pesky conscience
to go along for the ride.
A trained assassin, Daken actually defeated
his dad and stuck him in a vat of water to
drown, since — even with a healing factor
— Wolverine still needs to wolver-breathe.
However, after a timely rescue by Deadpool,
Wolverine got free, tracked down Daken, and
in a bit of karmic retribution, drowned him
in a puddle.
Bad dad!
More kids, more murder
The Mongrels were a team of supervillains
sent to fight Wolverine by a secret group
of bad guys who called themselves the Red
Right Hand, since apparently every good team
name was already taken.
After being trapped in hell — don't ask
— Wolverine gets free and goes on one of
his patented revenge benders,
"Revenge Rampage!"
killing all the Mongrels in the process.
It's only after they're all dead that the
Red Right Hand reveals the Mongrels were all
children of Wolverine, and it was all a big
ploy to make him feel really bad about himself.
Way to think small, guys!
He tortured an American soldier
Frank Simpson was an abused, mentally disturbed
child who killed his own mother.
Things somehow actually got worse for Frank,
though, when Wolverine murdered his father
and then forced him to join a government program
that manufactures superhumans.
After emerging from the program a total wreck,
Frank was sent to Vietnam, where a sadistic
Wolverine then tortured and brainwashed him
into becoming the mindless murder machine
known as Nuke.
So….
Why exactly is Logan considered a good guy
again?
Oh, right, because Hugh Jackman sings.
"Who am I?
I'm Wolverine!"
He set up Colossus for a beatdown
Wolverine's fellow X-Men Colossus and Kitty
Pryde have long had an on-again, off-again
romance.
Back when Colossus first dumped Kitty, though,
Wolverine was none too happy about how his
comrade handled the situation.
So he decided to teach Colossus a lesson by
getting him drunk and then letting Juggernaut
deliver a massive beatdown on the overmatched
hero.
Yup.
While Nightcrawler wants to intervene and
help their friend, Wolverine refuses, insisting
that Colossus has it coming for being such
a heartless cad.
He's not necessarily wrong, and compared to
repeatedly murdering his own children, it's
pretty low on the list of bad things Wolverine
has done.
But, you know.
Think twice before enlisting Logan as your
wingman.
An infinite number of jerks
In the comics, there's an infinite number
of alternate universes, meaning there's an
infinite number of jerks named Wolverine running
around doing horrible things.
Don't believe it?
Well, say hello to Wolverine the vampire lord,
who, after being turned into a vampire by
Dracula, infects the rest of the X-Men.
And then they go on a murderous spree, killing
the rest of the superheroes.
Like you do.
Then there's the Age of Apocalypse Logan,
who called himself Weapon Omega.
His plan was to help alien beings called the
Celestials completely wipe out all humanity,
because… reasons.
Naturally, in the course of the story, he
also murdered his own daughter, because that
is apparently just how Wolverine rolls.
Then there's the infamous, original Old Man
Logan storyline, which was one of the inspirations
for the movie Logan.
In the comic book version, Logan swears off
violence after he is tricked by an illusionist
named Mysterio into murdering all of the X-Men.
This is what happens when you never learn
anger control, dude.
Ultimate creep
As bad as all those other versions of Wolverine
are, the worst has to be the Ultimate Universe
Wolverine, who is consistently written as
an amoral villain who just happens to be working
for the X-Men.
It's impossible to list all of his misdeeds,
but among the worst are the time he straight
up murdered a scared mutant kid because he
was worried about bad publicity for mutants
after the boy lost control of his powers.
Then there's the time he tried to kill Cyclops
because he wanted to make out with Jean Grey.
But probably the worst is when Jean Grey mind-swapped
Logan with the teenage Peter Parker to teach
Logan a lesson, only to have Wolverine use
it as an excuse for some very inappropriate
interactions with underage high school girls.
Face it: Wolverine is just messed up.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!